the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
this chapter will not be part of the
midterm everything else will be and so
all the way up to goodness-of-fit tests
and there will be a some practice exams
that will be posted in the recitation
section of the course and that will be
you will be working on so the recitation
tomorrow will be a review session for
the midterm I'll send an announcement by
email ok so going back to our estimator
we showed that the least squares
estimator in the case where we had some
Gaussian observations so we had
something that looked like this Y was
equal to some matrix x times beta plus
some Epsilon this was an equation that
was happening in R to the N for n
observations and then we wrote the least
squares estimator beta hat ok and for
the purpose from here on where you see
that you have this normal distribution
this Gaussian p variate distribution
that means that at some point we've made
the assumption that epsilon were an ax +
dimensional 0 identity of our n times
the time Sigma square which I kept on
forgetting about last time all right I
will try not to do that this time and so
from this we derived a bunch of
properties of this least squares
estimator beta hat and in particular one
the key thing that everything was built
on was that we could write beta hat as
the true unknown beta plus some
multivariate Gaussian that was centered
but had a weird covariance structure so
that was definitely P dimensional and it
was Sigma squared times X X
so that's X transpose X and that's
inverse right yeah and the way we
derived that was by having a lot of at
least one cancellation between X
transpose X and X transpose X inverse ok
so this is the basis for inference in
linear in linear regression so in a way
that's correct because what happened is
that we use the fact that X beta hat
once we have this beta X beta hat is
really just a projection of Y onto the
linear span of the columns of X right or
the column span of X and so in
particular those things Y minus X beta
hats are called residuals so that's the
vector of residuals what's the dimension
of this of this vector and by one right
so those things we can sort of write as
epsilon hat right there sort of an
estimate for this epsilon because we
just put a hat on on beta and from this
one we could actually build an
investigator of Sigma hat squared and
that was this guy okay and we showed
that indeed the right normalization for
this was n minus P because Y minus X
beta hat two norm is actually a chi
square within minus P degrees of freedom
and so that's his up to this scaling by
Sigma square so that's what we came up
with and something I told you which
follows from Cochrane's theorem we did
not go into details about this but
essentially since one of them
corresponds to projection onto the
linear span of the columns of X and the
other one corresponds to projection onto
the orthogonal of this guy
and we're in a gas in case things that
are orthogonal are actually independent
in a Gaussian case so from a geometric
point of view you can sort of understand
everything you think of your subspace of
the linear span of the X's sometimes you
project onto this guy sometimes you
project onto it's orthogonal beta hats
corresponds to projection onto the
linear span I've sown hats correspond to
a projection onto the orthogonal and
those things tend to be independent and
that's why you have that beta hat is
independent of Sigma square of Sigma hat
square okay so it's really just a
statement about two linear spaces being
orthogonal I would respect to each other
so we we left at this on this slide last
time and what I claim is that this thing
here is actually so oh yeah the other
thing we want to use so that's good for
beta hat but since we don't know what
Sigma Square is if we knew what Sigma
square is that would totally be enough
for us but we also need this extra thing
that Sigma square hat square over Sigma
square follows and there's an N minus P
this follows a chi square with n minus P
degrees of freedom and Sigma hat squared
is independent of beta hat right so
that's going to be something we need so
that's useful if Sigma squared is
unknown and again sometimes it might be
known if you're using some sort of you
know measurement device or which is
right on the side of the box okay so
from these two things we're gonna be
able to do inference and inference right
we said there's I mean there's three
pillars to inference the first one is
estimation and we've been doing that so
far right we've constructed this least
squares estimator which happens to be
the maximum likelihood estimator in the
gaussian case the two other things we do
in in inference or confidence intervals
and we can do confidence intervals we're
not going to do much because we're gonna
talk about they're sort of cousin which
are tests okay and that's really where
the statistical inference comes into and
here we're going to be interested in a
very specific kind of test for linear
regression and those are tests of the
form
Bena Jaso the jet coefficient of beta is
equal to zero and that's going to be our
null hypothesis versus h1 where beta J
is C not equal to zero and for the
purpose of regression unless you have
lots of domain-specific knowledge it
won't be beta g+ or beta u- it's really
not not nonzero that's interesting to
you okay so why would I want to do this
test well if I expand this thing where I
have y is equal to X beta plus Epsilon
so what happens if I look for example at
the first coordinate so so I have that Y
is actually so say y1 is equal to beta 1
plus beta 2 X 1 well that's actually
complicated let me write it like this
beta 0 plus beta 1 X 1 plus beta P minus
1 X P minus 1 plus Epsilon and that's
true for all eyes right ok and this is
right so this is beta 1 x 1 that was our
first coordinate ok so that's just
expanding this going back to the to the
scalar form rather than going to the
matrix vector form ok that's what we're
doing when I write y is equal to X beta
plus epsilon I I assume that each of my
Y's can be represented as a linear
combination of the X's the first one
being 1 plus some epsilon I everybody
agrees with this what does it mean for
beta J to be equal to 0
yes
yeah that XG doesn't even show up in
this thing right so if B H is equal to 0
that means that essentially we can
remove the J's coordinate X J from all
observations okay so for example I'm a
banker and I'm trying to predict some
score let's call it Y without the noise
right so I'm trying to predict what is
going to be your score that's something
that should be sort of telling me how
likely you are to reimburse your loan on
time right or do you have late payments
where actually maybe these days bankers
are actually looking at how much late
fees can I will I be collecting from you
right maybe that's what they are more
after rather than make sure that your
aim versus everything they're trying to
maximize this number of late fees and
they collect a bunch of things about you
definitely your credit score but maybe
your zip code profession years of
education family status a bunch of
things right one might be your shoe size
okay and then one I know maybe shoe size
is actually a good explanation for how
much fees they're gonna be collecting
from you but as you can imagine this
would be a controversial thing to bring
in people might want to tie for their
shoe size is a good idea and so they
would just look at the J corresponding
to shoe size and test whether shoe size
should appear or not in this formula
okay and that's essentially the kind of
thing that people are going to do now if
I do genomics and I'm trying to predict
the size the girth of a pumpkin for a
competition based on some genomic
available data of available genomic data
then I can test whether gene J which is
called I don't know P snap 24 and always
have these crazy names appears or not in
this formula is that is the gene piece
nap 24 could be important or not for the
size of the final pumpkin so those are
definitely the important things and
definitely we want to put
beta J not equal to zero as the
alternative because that's where in
scientific discovery shows up okay and
so to do that well we're in a Gaussian
setup so we know that even if we don't
know what Sigma hat is we can actually
call for a t-test okay so how did we
build the t-test in general well we had
something that looked like so before
what we had was something that looked
like theta hat followed was equal to
theta plus some n0 and something that
depended on n maybe write something like
this Sigma squared over n right so
that's what it looked like now what we
have is that beta hat is equal to beta
plus some n but this time it's p variate
and then X transpose X inverse Sigma
squared so it's actually very similar
except that the matrix x transpose x
inverse is now replacing just this
number 1 over n but it's playing the
same role so in particular this implies
that's for every j from 1 to p what is
the distribution of beta hat J well beta
hat J is actually equal to so all I have
to do so this is a system of P equations
and all I have to do is to read the PJ
throw right so it's telling me here I'm
gonna read beta hat J here I'm gonna
read beta J and here I need to read what
is the distribution of the jate
coordinate of this guy right so this is
a Gaussian vector so I need to
understand what this definition is okay
so how do I do this well the observation
that that's actually useful for this
maybe I shouldn't use the word
observation in stats class so it's
called a claim the interesting claim is
that if I want if I if I'm interest if I
have a vector
let's call it V then V J is equal to V
transpose EJ where EJ is the vector with
0 0 0 and then a 1 on the jet coordinate
and then 0 elsewhere that's the jet
coordinate ok so that the J's vector of
the canonical basis of our P right so
now that I have this form I can see that
essentially beta hat J is just EJ
transpose this NP 0 Sigma squared X
transpose X inverse right
and now I know what the distribution of
the inner product between a Gaussian and
a vector deterministic vector is what is
it it's a Gaussian right so all I have
to check is that II J transpose NP 0
Sigma squared X transpose X inverse well
this is equal in distribution to what
well this is gonna be a one-dimensional
thing right and inner product is just a
real number okay so it's going to be
some Gaussian the mean is going to be 0
in a product with EJ which is 0 what is
the variance of this guy who actually
use this except that EJ was not a vector
but it was a matrix right so what we do
is we to see so the rule is that V
transpose say n nu Sigma is equal is sum
n mu V transpose mu and then the
transpose Sigma V right that's the rule
or Gaussian vectors that's just a
property of Gaussian vectors so what do
we have here well eg plays the role of V
and Sigma square X transpose X inverse
is the role of Sigma sorry I'm left with
EJ transpose let me pull out the Sigma
square here
okay but this thing is what happens if I
take a matrix I pre multiply it by this
vector EJ and I post multiplied by this
vector AJ I'm claiming that I'm actually
this corresponds to only one single
element of this matrix which one is it
jace diagonal element right so this
thing here is nothing but X transpose X
inverse inverse and then the J diagonal
element is JJ now I cannot go any
further right X transpose X inverse can
be a complicated matrix and I do not
know how to express its JJ's diagonal
element much better than this actually
well no actually I don't
right it involves basically all the
coefficients yeah yeah from this rule so
you always pre and post multiply when
you talk about the covariance because if
you did not it would be a vector and not
a scalar for one but in general think of
V as a matrix it's still true of any
visa matrix that's compatible with pre
multiplying by some Gaussian okay any
other question yeah
so for any vector V any other question
all right so now we've sort of
identified that this the Jade
coefficient of this Gaussian which I can
represent from the claim as VJ transpose
this guy is also a Gaussian that's
centered and its covariance its variance
now as Sigma squared times the J
diagonal element of X transpose X
inverse so the conclusion is that beta
hat J is equal to beta J plus some N and
I'm gonna emphasize the fact that now
it's one-dimensional with mean 0 and
covariance Sigma squared X transpose X
inverse inverse JJ now if you look at
the last line of the second board and
the first line on the first board those
are basically the same thing right beta
hat J is my theta hat beta J is my theta
and the variance Sigma square over N is
now Sigma squared times this J J's
element now the inverse sort of suggests
that it looks like the inverse of n so
those things are gonna we're gonna want
to think of those guys as being some
sort of 1 over N kind of statement ok
so from this the fact that those two
things are the same leads us to believe
that we are now equipped to perform the
test that we're trying to do because
under the null hypothesis
beta J is known is known it's equal to
zero so I can remove it and I have to
deal with this Sigma square if Sigma
square is known then I can just perform
a regular Gaussian test using Gaussian
quintel's and if Sigma square is unknown
I'm gonna just divide by Sigma squared
and multiplied by Sigma hat and and then
I'm gonna basically get my t-test okay
so actually for the purpose of your exam
i really suggest that you understand
every single word i'm gonna be saying
now because this is exactly the same
thing that you're expected to know from
other courses right because right now
i'm just going to apply exactly the same
technique that we did for the single
parameter estimation okay so what do we
have now is that under h0 beta j is
equal to zero therefore beta hat j
follows some n0 Sigma squared and I'm
gonna call this just like I do in the
slide I'm gonna call this gamma J so
gamma J is this X transpose X inverse
JJJ diagonal element okay so that
implies that beta hat J over Sigma oh it
was it square root yeah Sigma square
root of gamma J follows some n 0 1 so I
can form my test statistic which to be
reject if the absolute value of beta hat
J divided by Sigma square root gamma J
is larger than what can somebody tell me
what I want this to be larger than to
reject Q alpha
everybody agrees of what of of this guy
right with the standard notation that
this is the quintile do everybody agrees
however - right so not everybody should
be agreeing thank you you're the first
one to disagree with yourself which is
probably good stuff / - because of the
absolute value right I want to just be
away from this guy and that because I
have right so the Alpha over to the the
sanity check should be that H one is
beta J not equal to zero so that works
if Sigma is known right because I need
to know Sigma to be able to build my
test so if Sigma is unknown well I can
tell you use this test but you're gonna
be like okay when I'm going to have to
plug in some numbers I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be stuck
but if Sigma is unknown we have Sigma
hat squared as an estimator right let me
write Sigma square here so in particular
beta hat divided by Sigma hat squared
times root gamma J something I can
compute right sorry that's beta hat J
right right I can compute that thing
agreed now I have Sigma hat J what I
need to do is to be able to compute the
distribution of this thing so I know the
distribution of beta hat J over square
root of gamma J that's some Gaussian
zero one I don't know exactly what the
distribution of Sigma hat J squared is
but what I know is this that was
actually written maybe here is that n
minus P Sigma hat J square Sigma hat
over Sigma Sigma hat squared over Sigma
square follows some Chi square with n
minus P degrees of freedom and that it's
actually independent of beta hat J it's
independent of beta hat so it's
independent of each of its coordinate
right that was part of your homework
where you had to some of you were
confused by the fact that I mean if
you're independent of something of some
big thing you're independent of all the
smaller components of this big thing
that's basically what you need to know
okay and so now I can just write this as
this is beta hat J divided by so now I
want to make this guy up here so it's
beta hat J Sigma squared over Sigma
squared Sigma hat squared over Sigma
squared times n minus P divided by
square root gamma J so that's what I
want to see right yeah
yeah so I write this I decided to write
this I could have put make the Mickey
Mouse here it just wouldn't make sense I
just decide to take this thing right
okay so no let okay so I take this guy
and now I'm gonna rewrite it as
something I want
because right if you don't know what
Sigma is sorry that's not sick
you mean this square thank you yes
that's correct okay so you don't know
what Sigma is you replace it by Sigma
add that's the most natural thing to do
you just now want to find out what the
what the distribution of this guy is so
this is not exactly what I had to be
able to get this I need to divide by
Sigma squared sorry I need to I'm sorry
that's correct now okay and now I have
that sorry I should not write it like
that it's not what I want what I want is
this and to be able to get this guy what
I need is Sigma hat a sigma over Sigma
hat
square root and then I need to have to
make this thing show up right so I need
to have this n minus P show up and the
denominator so to be able to get it I
need to multiply the entire thing by
square root of n minus P okay so this is
just a tautology I just squeezed in what
I wanted but not this whole thing here
this is actually of the form beta hat J
divided by Sigma over square root gamma
J and then divided by square root of
Sigma hat squared over Sigma squared no
I don't want to divide it by a square
root n minus P sorry and now it's times
n minus P divided by n minus P okay and
what is the distribution of this thing
here
so I'm gonna I'm gonna keep going here
so the distribution of this thing here
is what well this numerator what is this
distribution
and see what it's actually still ran
over there right so that's around 0 1
what is the distribution of this guy
sorry I don't think you have color again
okay so what is the distribution of this
guy this is still written on the board
it's the chi-square that I have right
here so that's a chi square n minus P
divided by n minus P degrees of freedom
the only thing I need to check is that
those two guys are independent which is
also what I have from here and so that
implies that beta hat J divided by Sigma
hat square root of gamma J what is the
distribution of this guy
and - P was that crystal clear for
everyone was that so simple that it was
boring to everyone okay good that's
where the point at which you should be
this alright so now I have this I can
read the quintiles of this guy so my
test statistic becomes about my
rejection region I reject if the
absolute value of this new guy exceeds
the quintile of order alpha over two but
this time of a TN minus P and now you
can actually see that the only
difference between this tests and that
test apart from replacing Sigma by Sigma
hat is that now I've moved from the
quantiles of a Gaussian to the quantiles
of a TN minus P and what's actually
somewhat interesting from this
perspective what's actually interesting
from this perspective is that the TN
minus P we know has heavier tails than
the Gaussian but they've the number of
degrees of freedom
richy's maybe 30 or 40 it's they're
virtually the same and here the number
of degrees of freedom is not given only
by n but it's n minus P so if I have
more and more parameters to estimate
this will result in some heavier heavier
tails and that's just to account for the
fact that it's harder and harder to
estimate the variance when I have a lot
of parameters
okay that's basically where it's coming
from so now let's move on to let's move
on to well okay so this is the simplest
test and actually if you run any
statistical software for least squares
the output in any of them will look like
this you will have a sequence of rows
and you're going to have an estimate for
beta 0 an estimate for beta 1 etc
here you're gonna have a bunch of things
and on this rule you're gonna have like
the value here so that's going to be
what's estimated by Lee squares and then
the second line immediately is the the
is gonna be well either the value of
this thing so let's call it t and then
there's going to be the p value
corresponding to this T this is
something that's just routinely coming
out because and then there's of course
the last line for people who cannot read
numbers that's really just giving you
little stars they're not stickers but
that's close to it and and that's just
saying well I have three stars
I'm very significantly different from
zeros if I have two star I'm moderately
differently from 0 and if I have one
star it means well just give me another
thousand dollars and I will sign that
it's actually different from zero okay
so that's basically the kind of outputs
everybody sees what I mean by that so
what I mean what I'm trying to emphasize
here is that those things are so routine
when you're running your regression
because people stuff and maybe even if
you have two hundred observations you're
gonna stuff in maybe twenty variables P
equals twenty let's still a big number
to interpret what's going on and it's
nice for you if you can actually trim
some fat out okay and so the problem is
that when you start doing this and then
this and then this and then this the
probability that you make a mistake in
your test right the probability that you
erroneously reject the null here is five
percent here it's five percent here it's
five percent here it's five percent and
at some point you know if things happen
with five percent chances and you keep
on doing them over and over again
they're gonna start to happen so you can
see that basically what's happening is
that you actually have an issue is that
you might not if you start repeating
those tests you might not be at five
percent error at some point and so what
you do to prevent from that if you want
to test all those beta J simultaneously
you have to do what's called upon for
okay and the bonferroni correction
follows from what's called a Union bound
a Union bound is actually so if you're
computer scientists you're very familiar
with it if you're a mathematician
that's just essentially the third axiom
of probability that you see that the
probability of the Union is less than
the sum of the probabilities right
that's the Union bound and you of course
can generalize that to more than two and
that's exactly what you're doing here
okay so let's see how we would want to
perform bonferroni correction to control
the probability that they are all equal
to 0 at the same time right so recall so
if I want to perform this test over
there where I want to test h0 that beta
j is equal to 0 for all j in some subset
s so right so think of s included and 1p
you can think of it as being all of one
of P if you want right it really doesn't
matter s is something that's given to
you maybe you want to test you the
subset of them but maybe you want to
test all of them versus h1 beta J is not
equal to 0 for some Jane s right that's
a test that tests all these things at
once and if you actually look at this
table all at once implicitly you're
performing this test for all of the rows
for s equal 1 to P you will do that
whether you like it or not you will so
now let's look at what the probability
of type 1 error looks like ok so I want
the probability of type pointer so
that's the probability when h0 is true
that well so let me call CJ the
indicator that say beta J hat
or Sigma hat square roots gamma J
exceeds Q alpha over 2 of T and minus V
right so we know that those are the
tests that I perform here I just add
this extra index J to tell me that I'm
actually testing the J's coefficient
okay so what I want is the probability
that under the null so that those are
all equal to zero that maybe that beta
J's that I will reject to the
alternative for one of them right so
that's Phi 1 is equal to 1 or side 2 is
equal to 1 all the way to PI well let's
just say that this is the entire thing
because it's annoying okay I mean you
can check the slide if you want to do it
more generally but sorry P is is equal
to okay or more everybody agrees that
this is the probability of type 1 error
all right so either I reject this one or
this one or this one or this one or this
one and that's exactly what I'm gonna
reject at least one of them ok so this
is the probability of type 1 error and
what I want is to chip this guy less
than alpha okay but what I know is to
control the probability that this guy is
less than alpha the dis guy is less than
alpha the dis guy is less than alpha in
particular if all these guys are
disjoint then this could really be the
sum of all these probabilities so in the
worst case
if Sai J equal one intersected with site
J equals one is the empty set so that
means those are called disjoint sets
you've seen this terminology in
probability right so if those sets are
disjoint for all of them right for all J
different from K then this probability
well let me write it as star then star
is equal to well the probability under
h0 that's I 1 is equal to 1 plus the
probability and there is 0
that's like P is equal to 1 now if I use
this test with this alpha here then this
probability is equal to alpha this
probability is also equal to alpha so
the probability of type 1 error is
actually not equal to alpha is equal to
P alpha so what is the solution here
well it's to run those guys with not
with alpha but with alpha over P and if
I do this then this guy is equal to
alpha over P this guy is equal to alpha
over P and so when I get those things I
get P times alpha over P which is just
alpha ok so all I do is rather than
running each of the tests with
probability of error
so that's a test at level alpha or P
okay that's actually very stringent if
you think about it from one second even
if you have only five observed five
variables P equals five and you started
with the test you wanted to do your test
at 5% it forces you to do the test at 1%
for each of those variables if you have
10 variables I mean you know that starts
to be a very stringent so it's gonna be
harder and harder for you to make to
conclude to the alternative now one
thing I need to tell you is that here I
said if they are disjoined and those
probabilities are equal but if they're
not disjoint the Union bound tells me
that the probability of the Union is
less than the sum of the probabilities
and so now I'm not exactly equal to
alpha but I'm bounded by alpha alright
and that's where that's why bonferroni
correction people are not super
comfortable with this because in reality
you never think that those tests are
gonna be completely giving you
completely disjoint things right I mean
why would it be why would it be that if
this guy is equal to one then all the
other ones are equal to zero why would
it make any sense right so this is
definitely conservative but the problem
is that we don't know how to do much
better I mean we have a formula that
tells you the probability of the Union
has some crazy sum that looks at all the
intersection and all these little things
right I mean it's a generalization of P
of a or B is equal to P of a plus P of B
minus probability of the intersection
right but if you start doing this for
more than two it's super complicated the
number of terms grows really fast but
most importantly even if you go here you
still need to control probably of the
intersection and those tests that are
not necessarily independent if they were
independent that would be easier
probably of the intersection would be
the product of the probabilities but
those things are super correlated and so
it doesn't really help and so we'll see
when we talk about high dimensional
stats to
at the end that there's something called
false discovery rate which is
essentially saying listen if I want to
control this thing if I really define my
probability of type 1 error as this I
want to make sure that I never make this
kind of error I'm doomed
this is just not gonna happen but I can
sort of revise what my goals are in
terms of of errors that I make and then
I will actually be able to do and that
what people are looking at is false
discovery rate and this is called
family-wise error rate which is a
stronger thing to control right so this
trick that consists in replacing alpha
by alpha over the number of times you're
going to be performing your test or
alpha over the number of terms in your
Union is actually called the bonferroni
correction okay and that's something you
use 1 you have what's called another key
word here is multiple testing all right
when you're trying to do multiple tests
simultaneously okay and if s is not all
of P well you just divide by the number
of tests that you're actually making
right so if s is of size K for some K
less than P you just divide alpha by K
and out by P of course when you can
always divide by P but it's you're gonna
make your life harder for no reason okay
any question about bumps around
correction all right
so one thing that is maybe not as
obvious as the test beta J equal to 0 vs
beta G not equal to 0 and in particular
what it means is that it's not going to
come up as a software output without
even you requesting it because this is
so standard that it's just coming out
but there's other tests that you might
think of that might be more complicated
and more tailored to your particular
problem and those tests are of the form
G times beta is equal to some lambda all
right so let's see the test we've just
done beta J equals 0 vs beta J not equal
to 0 is actually equivalent to VD j
transpose beta equals 0 vs aj transpose
beta a not equal to 0 right that was our
claim but now I'll have to stop here I
don't have to multiply by a vector and
test if it's equal to 0 I can actually
replace this by some general matrix G
and replace this guy by some general
vector lambda and I'm not telling you
what the dimensions are because they're
general I can take whatever I want take
your favorite matrix as long as the
right side of the matrix can be
multiplying B beta and lambda take it as
the as the number of rows of G and then
you can do that right
I can always form formulate this test
what will this test encompass well those
are kind of weird test right so you can
think of things like I want to test if
beta 2 plus beta 3 are equal to 0 for
example maybe I want to test if
beta 5 minus 2 beta 6 is equal to 23
well that's weird but why would you want
to test if beta 2 plus beta 3 is equal
to 0 maybe you want to know maybe you
don't want to know if you know that the
effect of some gene is not zero if you
know that this gene effects this trait
but you want to know if the effect of
this gene is canceled by the effect of
that gene and this is the kind of stuff
that you're gonna be testing for that ok
now this guy is much more artificial and
I don't have a bedtime story to tell you
around this right so just you know those
things can happen and can be much more
complicated now here notice that the
matrix G has one row every for both of
the examples but if I want to test if
those two things happen at the same time
that I actually can take a matrix write
another matrix that can be useful is G
equals the identity of RP and lambda is
equal to 0
what am i doing here in this case what
is this test testing sorry this test
yeah yeah we're testing if the entire
vector beta is equal to 0 because G
times beta is equal to beta and we're
asking whether it's equal to 0 so the
thing is when you want to actually test
if a beta is equal to 0 you're actually
testing if your entire model everything
you're doing in life is just junk right
it's just telling you actually forget
about this wise X beta plus epsilon Y is
really just that so on there's nothing
there's just some big noise with some
big variance and there's nothing else
alright so turns out that's the
statistical software output that I wrote
here spits out an answer to this
question just the last line usually is
doing this test does your model even
make sense yeah it's probably for people
to check whether they actually just mix
their two data sets right maybe they're
actually trying to predict I don't know
some credit score from genomic data and
so just want to make sure maybe that's
not the right thing all right
so it turns out that the machinery is
exactly the same as the one we've just
taken all right so we actually start
from here so let me pull this up
right so we start from here beta hat was
equal to beta plus this guy okay and the
first thing we did was to say well beta
J is equal to this thing because well
beta J was just EJ times beta right so
rather than taking EJ here let me just
take G now we said that for any vector
no that was trivial so the thing we need
to know is what is this thing well this
thing here what is what is this guy it's
also normal the mean is zero again
that's just using properties of Gaussian
vectors and what is the covariance
matrix let's call this guy Sigma so that
you can make an answer I can formulate
an answer so if what is the distribution
of what is the covariance of G times
some Gaussian zero Sigma G Sigma G
transpose right so that's G X transpose
X and G transpose okay
now I'm not gonna be able to go much
further right I mean I made this very
cute observation that EJ transpose a
matrix times EJ is the Jeth diagonal
element now if I have a general matrix
the price to pays that I cannot just
shrink this thing any further because
I'm trying to be abstract okay and so
I'm almost there the only thing that
happened last time is that when this was
EJ under h0 we knew that this was equal
to zero under the null but under the
null what is this equal to lambda which
I know right I mean I wrote my thing and
in the couple instances I just showed
you including this one over there on top
lambda was equal to
but in general it can be any lambda but
what's key about this lambda is that
actually know it that's the formula
that's the hypothesis I'm formulating so
now I'm gonna have to be a little more
careful when I want to build the
distribution of G beta hat I need to
actually subtract this lambda okay so
now we go from this and we say well gee
theta hat minus lambda follows some np0
Sigma square G X transpose X inverse G
transpose right so that's true let's
assume let's go straight to the case
when we don't know what Sigma is so what
I'm going to be interested in is that is
G beta hat minus lambda divided by Sigma
hat and that's going to follow some
Gaussian that has this thing G X
transpose X inverse G transpose so now
what did I do last time right so clearly
the quintiles of this distribution is
well okay what is this site what is the
size of this distribution well I need to
tell you that G is and what do they take
here oh yeah you're right so let me
write it like this so
let me write it like this now Sigma
squared over Sigma okay so let's forget
about the size of G now let's just think
of any general gene when G was a vector
what was nice is that this guy was just
the scale a number just one number and
so if I wanted to get rid of the of this
in the right-hand side all I had to do
was to divide by this thing we called it
gamma J and we just had to divide by
square root of gamma Jen that would be
gone now I have a matrix right so I need
to get rid of this matrix somehow
because clearly the quintiles of this
distribution are not going to be written
at the back of a book for any value of G
and any value of x so I need to
standardize before I can read anything
out of a table so how do we do it well
we just form this this guy here okay so
what we know is that if so here's the
claim again that another claim about a
Gaussian vector if X follows some n 0
Sigma then X transpose Sigma inverse X
follow some K squared and here it's
going to depend on how many what is the
dimension here so if I make this a k by
k a k dimensional Gaussian vector this
is X square K okay where we used that
before yeah well step that's exactly
what we use right wall step had a chi
square that was showing up and the way
we made it show up was by taking the
asymptotic variance taking its inverse
which in this framework was called
Fisher information and then we pre and
post multiplied by this thing okay so
this is the key and so now it tells me
exactly when I start from this guy that
has this multivariate Gaussian it tells
me how to turn it into something that
has a distribution which is pivotal
right K square K is completely pivotal
does not depend on anything I don't know
and so the way I go from here
[Applause]
the way I go from here is by saying well
now I look at G beta hat minus lambda
transpose and now I need I need to look
at the inverse of the matrix over there
so it's G X transpose X inverse G
inverse G beta hat minus lambda this guy
is gonna follow well here I need to
actually divide by Sigma in this case if
G is K times P all right so that's what
I mean here is just that's the same K
okay that shows up is the number of
constraints that I have in my test right
okay so now if I go from here to using
Sigma hat the chief thing to observe is
that this guy is actually not a Gaussian
right I'm not going to have a student T
distribution that shows up so
that implies that if I take the same
thing okay so now I just go from Sigma
to Sigma hat then this thing is of the
form well this chi squared K divided by
the Chi square that shows up in the
denominator of the T distribution which
is square root of oh I should not divide
by Sigma square so this is Sigma square
right so this is Sigma square so this is
of the form divided by PI squared and
minus P divided by n minus P alright so
that's the same denominator that I saw
in my t-test the numerator has changed
though right the numerator is now this K
Square and no longer a Gaussian okay but
this distribution is actually pivotal as
long as we can guarantee that there's no
hidden parameter in the in the
correlation between the two K squares
right so again as all statements of
Independence in this class I will just
give it to you for free those two things
I claim so okay let's say admit
these are independent okay we're almost
there this could be a distribution
that's pivotal but there's something
that's a little unbalanced with it is
that this guy is divided by its number
of degrees of freedom but this guy is
not divided by its number of degrees of
freedom and so we just have too big the
extra step that if I divide this guy by
K then this guy is a chi square divided
by K if I divide this guy by K then I
get this guy divided by K okay and now
it looks I mean it doesn't change
anything right I've just divided by a
fixed number but it just looked more
elegant it's the ratio of two
independent chi-square that are
individually divided by the number of
degrees of freedom okay and this has a
name
and it's called a Fisher or F
distribution so unlike William shun
William Gossett who was not allowed to
use his own name and use the name
student Fisher was allowed to use his
own name and that's called the Fisher
distribution and the Fisher distribution
has now two parameters two sets a set of
two degrees of freedom one for the
numerator and one for denominator okay
so f or Fisher distribution so f is
equal to the ratio on the Chi square P
over P and a Chi square Q over Q so
that's a as P Q where the two K square
are independent okay is that clear what
I'm defining here so this is basically
what plays the role of T distributions
when you're testing more than one
parameter at a time so you basically
replace the know the normal that was in
the numerator you replace it by Chi
square because you're testing if two
vectors are simultaneously close and the
way you do it is by looking at their
squared norm and that how is the K
that's how the Chi square shows up quick
remark are those things really very
different right how can I relate a K
square with the T distribution well if T
follows say 80 let's call it Q okay so
that means that T let me look at
absolute no T is some n 0 1
/ the square root of a chi-squared q / q
right and that's the distribution of T
so if I look at the square of the
distributor of T squared well that's the
square of some n 0 1 divided by K square
Q over Q I agreed I just removed the
square root here and I took the square
of the Gaussian but what is the
distribution of a square of a Gaussian K
square with one degree of freedom right
so this is a K square with one degree of
freedom here it's also a category with
one degree of freedom divided by 1 so T
Square in the end has an F distribution
with 1 and Q degrees of freedom so those
two things are actually very similar the
only thing that's going to change is
that since we're actually looking at
typically absolute values of T when we
do our tests it's going to be exactly
the same thing this quintiles of one guy
are gonna be essentially square root of
the quantiles of the other guy that's
all it's gonna be right so my if my test
is sy is equal to the indicator that T
exceeds Q alpha over 2 of T Q for
example then it's equal to the indicator
that T squared XE q squared alpha over 2
T cubed because I had the absolute value
here which is equal to the indicator
that T squared is greater than Q alpha
over 2 and now this time it's an F 1 Q
so in a way those two things belong to
the same family there really are a
natural generalization of each other I
mean at least the F test is a
generalization of the Chi test
okay and so now I can perform my test
just like it's written here I just
formed this guy and then I perform
against the quantile of an f-test
notice there's no absolute value oh yeah
forget this is actually Q alpha because
T the F test the F statistic is already
positive so I'm not gonna look between
left and right I'm just gonna look
whether it's too large or not okay so
that's by definition so you can check if
you look at a table for student and you
look at the table for F 1 Q 1 it's just
gonna you're gonna have to move from one
column to the other because you're gonna
have to move from alpha over 2 to alpha
but 1 is gonna be square root up the
other one just like the K square is the
square of the of the Gaussian I mean if
you look at the K square one degree of
freedom you will see the same thing as
the as the Gaussian so all right
so okay I'm actually gonna I'm actually
gonna start with the last one because
you've been asking me a few questions
about why is my design deterministic so
there's many answers some are
philosophical but one that's actually
well there's the one that says
everything you cannot do if you don't
have a condition if you don't have X
because all the statements that we made
here for example just the fact that this
is case where if those starts those guys
start to be random variables then it's
clearly not gonna be a chi-square mean
cannot be a chi-square when those guys
are deterministic and when they are
random I mean things change so that's
just maybe one sanity's check statement
but i think the one that really matters
is that remember when we did the t-test
we had this gamma j that showed up gamma
j was playing the role of the variance
so here the variance you never think of
the I mean we'll talk about this in the
Bayesian setup but so far we haven't
thought of the variance as a random
variable and so here you X is really are
the parameters of your data and the
diagonal elements of X transpose X
inverse actually tell you what the
variance is so that's also one reason
why you should think of your X as being
deterministic number there are in a way
things that change the geometry of your
problem they just say oh let me look at
it from the perspectives of the
perspective of X actually for that
matter we didn't really spend much time
commenting on what is the effect of X
onto gamma right so remember gamma J all
right so that was the variance parameter
so we should try to understand what X is
lead to big variance and what X is lead
to small variance right that would be
nice
well if this is the identity matrix
let's say identity over N which is the
natural thing to look at because we want
this thing to scale like 1 over N then
this is just 1 over N we're back to the
original case yes oh yeah thank you X
yes so if this is the identity then well
the inverse is let's say just this guy
here is n times this guy so then the
inverse is 1 over n right so in this
case that means that gamma J is equal to
1 over N and
we're back to the theta-hat state our
case right the basic one-dimensional
thing what does it mean for a matrix for
when I take it uh yeah so that's of
dimension P right when I take its
transpose so forget about the scaling by
n right now this is just a matter of
scaling things right I can always
multiply my axis so that I have this
thing that shows up but when I have a
matrix if I look at X transpose X and I
get something which is the identity how
do I call this matrix orthogonal yeah
also normal or orthogonal so you call
this thing in our thermal matrix and
where it's an orthogonal matrix what it
means is that the so this matrix here if
you look at the matrix xx transpose the
entries of this matrix are the inner
products between the columns of X that's
what's happening right you can write it
and you will see that the the entries of
this matrix are the inner products if
it's the identity that means that you
get some ones and a bunch of 0s means
that all the eigen the inner products
between two different columns is
actually 0 what it means is that this
matrix X is an orthonormal basis for
your space the columns form an
orthonormal basis so they're basically
as far from each other as they can now
if I start making those guys closer and
closer then I'm starting to have some
issues right X transpose X is not gonna
be the identity I'm gonna start to have
some nonzero entries but if they all
remain of norm one then oh sorry so
that's for the inverse right so I first
start putting some stuff here which is
nonzero by taking my X's rather than
having this I move to this right now I'm
gonna start seeing some nonzero entries
and when I'm gonna take the inverse of
this matrix the diagonal elements are
gonna start to blow up sorry they're
going to start to become smaller and
smaller so when I take the inverse no
sorry the the diagonal elements are
gonna blow up and so what it means is
that the variance is gonna blow up and
that's essentially it's telling you that
if you if you get to choose your X's you
want to take them as orthogonal as you
can but
you don't then you just have to deal
with it and it will have a significant
impact on your on your estimation
performance and that's what also
routinely software statistical software
is gonna spit out this value here for
you and you're gonna have well actually
square root of this value and it's gonna
tell you essentially you're gonna know
how much randomness how much variation
you have in this particular parameter
that you're estimating so if gamma J is
large then you know you're gonna have
wide confidence intervals in your tests
are not gonna reject very much and
that's all captured by X that's what's
important everything all of this is
completely captured by X and of course
there was the Sigma square that showed
up here right
actually it was here even in the
definition of gamma J I forgot what is
the Sigma squared police the wing and so
this thing was here as well and that's
just sort of exogenous it comes from the
noise itself but there was this huge
factor that came from the X's itself
okay so let's go back now to reading
those displaced in a linear fashion so I
mean your MIT students you've probably
heard that correlation does not imply
causation many times maybe you don't
know what it means if you don't that's
okay you just have to know the sentence
no what it means is that it's not
because I decided that something was
gonna be the X and that something else
was gonna be the Y that whatever thing
I'm getting it means that X implies Y
right for example even if I do genetics
genomics or whatever I mean I sort of
implicitly assumed that the my genes are
gonna have an effect on my outside look
I could be the opposite right I mean Who
am I to say I'm not a biologist I don't
know I didn't open a biology book in 20
years so maybe you know if I start
hitting my head with a hammer I'm gonna
have changing my genetic material right
probably not but you know that's why
because but causation definitely does
not come from statistics if you know
that that's the different thing it's
actually gonna it's not coming from
there so actually I remember once I put
an exam to students and there was an old
dataset from police expenditures I think
in Chicago in the 60s and it was they're
trying to understand
I mean we know it was on crime was the
crime dataset and they were trying so
the y-variable was just a rate of crime
and the exes were a bunch of things and
one of them was policy expenditures and
if you ran the regression you would find
that the coefficient in front of police
expenditure was a positive number which
means that if you increase police
expenditures that increases the crime
right I mean that's what it means to
have a positive coefficient everybody
agrees with this fact right Peter J
Peter J is 10 then it means that if I
increase by $1 my police expenditure
eggman but I meant by 10 my crime
everything else being kept equal well
you know they were I think about 80% of
the students that were able to explain
to me that if you give more money to the
police then the crime is gonna raise
some people are like you know police is
making too much money and they don't
think about their work and they become
lazy and I mean people were really
coming up with some crazy things and
what it just meant is that no it's not
curly it's not causation right it's just
if you have more crime you give more
money to your police that's what's
happening right and that's all there is
so just be careful when you actually
draw some conclusions that causation is
a very important thing to keep in mind
and in practice unless you have external
sources of reason for causality for
example genetic material and and and
physical traits we sort of you know
agree upon what the arrow of causality
what the direction of the arrow of
causality is here there's places where
you might not
now finally the normality on the noise
everything with it today required normal
Gaussian distribution on the noise right
I mean it's everywhere there's some
Gaussian there's some Chi square
everything came out of Gaussian and for
that we needed this basic formula for
inference which we derived from the fact
that the noise was Gaussian itself if we
did not have that the only thing we
could write this beta hat is this number
or this vector we would not be able to
say the fluctuations of beta hat or this
guy will not be able to to do tests will
not be able to build the confidence
regions or anything and so this is an
important condition that we need and
that's what statistical software
by default but we now have a recipe on
how to do those tests right we can do it
either visually if we really want to
conclude that yes this is calcium using
our normal QQ plots and we can also do
it using our favorite test what test
should I be using to test that would
like two names yeah not the two Russians
I want a Russian and a scandinavian
person for this one what's that yeah
Lily something so common gruffly Lee
something test and so it's the comma
gross lee deforest test okay and because
i'm testing if they're gaussian and i'm
actually not really making any i don't
need to know what the variance is right
the mean is zero we saw that at the
beginning is zero by construction so we
actually don't need to think about the
meaning being zero itself this just
happens to be zero so we know that it's
zero but the variance we don't know so
we just want to know if it belongs to
the family of gaussians and so we need
to come over roughly Lefors for that and
that's also one of the things that spit
out by statistical software by default
when you run a linear regression
actually it spits out both como graph
smear and often come across clearly
forth probably contributing to the to
the widespread use of como graphs near
enough when you really shouldn't alright
so next time we will talk about more
advanced topics on regression but I
think I'm going to stop here for today
so again tomorrow sometime during the
day at least before the recitation you
will have a list of practice exercises
that will be posted and if you go to the
optional recitation you will have
someone solving them for you